I recently got another breast thermogram done. It's my first sense the full body was done at the
clinic two years ago. The full thermogram two years ago did not show any activity in the breast.
I was told that this was because frequently my type of cancer will not show up on a thermogram.
Yes, that's true. This most recent thermogram, however, did show activity at the tumor site.
Is this necessarily vascular activity that is feeding the cancer? Is it possible that it's
inflammation related to topically applying frankincense at DMSO every day? So what will show up on
a thermogram is metabolic activity. So metabolic activity can be cell growth and replication
cells. That's going to increase metabolic activity and in any increase in metabolic activity
is going to increase heat. So what a thermogram is reading is heat.
Now, thermograms have negatives to them too. So some breast cancers don't replicate quickly,
therefore don't produce a lot of heat. Some cancers, the breast cancer, are too deep
to actually have the heat be expressed on the surface of the body, therefore you can't really see
about a thermogram. So it's not highly beneficial for a colon cancer or something.
But increased vascularization could increase heat. So that's a possibility.
But certainly doing anything topical on the skin is going to increase heat. So in this case,
I would say if you have been applying frankincense at DMSO on a daily basis,
I'd say you got about 99% chance. That's what it's fun. Now, if you really wanted to test it,
you'd stop doing that for a period of time. And it's in a German period of time because you don't
know how long that that's going to take, but at least two weeks before doing it on a thermogram.
But that would be one way to test it.